we talked about the two-square theorem
this concerns prime numbers you know the
numbers which are only divisible by 1
and themselves the question how to write
a prime number as the sum of two squares
of natural numbers of positive natural
numbers the easiest example is take the
prime number 2 the smallest prime number
you can write this as 1 square plus 1
squared let's try the next prime 3 1
square plus 1 square viously not 1
square plus 2 square already too big so
so are 5 1 square plus 2 squared works
that's 2/3 for example 7 you try 1
squared plus 6 6 is not a square 2
squares 4 plus 3 3 is not a square are
we see it's not possible and the
question is do there exist natural
numbers x and y such that he is x square
plus y squared we asking for a simple
criterion which for an arbitrary prime
number we know that they are arbitrary
large prime numbers say with 10 million
digits you tell me or I tell you can be
written after sum of two squares or not
and if the prime number is so large we
cannot try it out like we did with these
small Prime's
I will live here for a formula or like a
like a way to get those squares or just
no impossible that would be great
nobody knows the formula you you can
only decide if you have good luck
whether it is possible at all not a
formula which gives you x and y if you
would give me some prime numbers say you
search on the internet for large prime
numbers you give me 1 and tell professor
now tell me yes or no and then
and within a second I will tell you yes
or no but you might be able to tell me
what tie squares are absolutely not
nobody will be able not only me I
suggest that we look into the history
Reef Lee who did this first this is the
famous French mathematician Pierre
fam'ly
who did other important things and he
liked such easy to formulate problems
and what did he do with these problems
he made tests he made long tables so he
took the F here for primes
he took the primes up to hundred the
primes up to thousand wrote down this
list and checked by hand case by case if
you do that we can we should show such a
list at the first glance you don't see
any pattern but Firma finally observed a
very very simple rule and that's already
his theorem which i write down now prime
number P is the sum of two squares if
and only if we subtract one from P get a
nice number if this number is divisible
by four that that means you can make a
very very simple test so let's consider
small prime let's say 17 we subtract 1
we get 16 ah divisible by 4 it works and
now we check is it really true and we
see our 17 is 4 times 4 plus 1 times 1
true let's consider 23 other nice prime
we subtract 1 get 22 not divisible by 4
so I you can try it yourself at home you
will not be able to write it as the sum
of two squares and the remarkable thing
is this is an easy test to subtract and
to check whether it's divisible by 4 is
very easy and you can try now on the
Internet write down huge prime numbers
subtract one try 2/4 and you know here
you go and you will not be able to find
X&Y he saw it and he tested it again and
again we don't know whether he wrote
down a proof he said it's a theorem but
he is famous for this he likes when he
was convinced that something is true he
probably believed in God and in the in
the order in the world and he said if I
see this so often it must be true so he
wrote our theorem but without proof and
the mathematicians after him varlet
about the proof very good mathematicians
and could not do it hundred years later
the Swiss mathematician Allah gave the
first proof that tricky proof
complicated too complicated for this
video first proof then 50 years later
Gauss gave a completely different proof
70 years later bida 'can't gave again a
completely different proof so the
mathematicians like to give different
proofs of the same theorem because of
every proof sheds light on the statement
and all these proofs had different light
on the statement so that all these
proofs are too complicated even to speak
about that here but about fifty years
ago
the mathematician done segi from Bonn
gave the famous one sentence proof and
that we are going to talk about one
sentence in one sentence of course you
will see for an ingenious mathematician
like Sergei it can be done in one
sentence for ordinary mathematicians
like me I need already ten sentences and
for ordinary people we will add a few
more
at numbers in particular positive
numbers because of if you would have
infinitely many solutions then these
numbers would get arbitrary large and P
is a fixed number so we get would get on
the right side numbers which are larger
than P